hi there it's Kevin van ORD standing in
for reviewer josiah renauldi to tell you
about counter spy counter spy is a slick
operation it's responsive action and
movement keep the tempo moving at a
steady clip precise gunplay and melee
combat give you tactical freedom and
rich customization options give you new
ways to play it's procedurally generated
missions the short runtime and some
scattered glitches can bug you but
CounterSpy superb presentation and
satisfying executions make for an
excellent adventure regardless
it's counter spies simplicity that makes
it so instantly appealing the
side-scrolling missions have you jumping
and shooting your way through a series
of safeguarded rooms in order to grab
critical Intel natural cover provides
plenty of chances to slow down and pick
your shots but quickly popping off a few
rounds once you elevate suspicion can be
just as efficient you're encouraged to
silently snap necks and land headshots
but you're crafty spy has enough raw
firepower to deal with the repercussions
of being spotted it's easy to pick up
and play but that doesn't mean that the
game lacks depth peeking over cover
alters your perspective transforming
counter spy into more of a shooting
gallery than a 2d side-scroller leaning
against walls looks to fire at enemies
in the distance deepening the
environments this perspective shift
occasionally breaks of beauty mechanics
you might awkwardly wrap your arms
around guards who are standing in the
background for instance what does and
doesn't grab someone's attention might
also shift from one cover spot to the
next
still emptying rounds into enemies on
multiple planes without alerting a soul
is genuinely satisfying search the area
the most obvious armament to have at the
ready is your silenced pistol but if
things get hairy you do have options
collecting schematics unlocks new
weapons to take into the field so feel
free to pull out an assault rifle of
your mob by guards modifiers offer
advantages like greater endurance and
silent steps even when you run of course
everything costs a bit of in-game cash
and since purchased modifiers disappear
after you finish a level you have to
cleverly budget your resources but as
long as you play smart and explore you
won't be short on money getting spotted
won't result in mission failure but
there are consequences if you don't
practice restraint counter spy takes
place in an alternate cold war setting
so there's an ever-present threat of a
nuclear attack hanging over your head
it's a constant race against a doomsday
clock and getting caught will expedite
the launch it's your job to keep both
the imperialist States and the Socialist
Republic at bay by monitoring their
alert States the 60 setting is best
represented through counter spies smooth
jazz jingles and cel-shaded aesthetics
which are sharp on both the PlayStation
Vita and on consoles period-appropriate
uniforms and propaganda create a strong
sense of place while deep reds and blues
proved consistently striking regrettably
it's over before you've had enough no
two levels are the same so you can keep
rolling the dice before reaching the
game's conclusion in order to discover
fresh level geometry nonetheless it only
takes a couple of hours to reach the end
leaving you wanting a lot more it might
be short but CounterSpy is a satisfying
adventure with responsive gunplay and a
lovingly crafted presentation this is a
stealth game that makes you feel as
silent as you are deadly and it's
wonderfully holy refreshing
you